[Music]
in couch potato news submitted by
biggest fan yes oh thank you young woman
lands dream job testing sofas for 10
hours a day after you lion mattresses I
would be so good at testing mattresses
you like hard mattress soft mattress I
like soft but it gives a little mmm
hahahaha mmm a little unit you don't
want it so software it's just like you
just bend you in half you want to it is
a little bit of support and then but not
too much support where it gets all hot
on you I want one of those like sofas or
beds that you can do this with like a
remote control oh sit in the Sleep
Number never your face at your feet all
the time yeah well you guys you have
like our beds or soft beds
so I like a cloud yeah a supportive
class I like yeah it's a portable toilet
not an actual cloud I sleep on the no I
I love it we put a cardboard box click
on it around I sleep upside down yeah I
love Tim pour cloud so it's like the the
kind of model where you sleep on the
receipt on it defines like your whatever
your body type is but it's still soft I
am we are there you sink in and it's so
called the tempur-pedic mattress ones I
got tempur-pedic but I also have a
memory foam on top of my tentacles [ __ ]
okay grandpa
and then you sink again Jane you get
like the computing brand yeah the bed is
a tempurpedic no is it the brand yes and
poor who she's got a hard and expensive
eye lower than that I was like 4,000 oh
you said yeah I'm one of those in
Finland and I'm missing it every night
here especially being you know pulled
all the stunts that I did back in the
past and every joint aches you start
appreciating what you sleep order what
you see that repeated and expensive but
if you get a Cal King tempur-pedic as I
told 12 G's what ontology it's [ __ ]
expensive it's like a car it is I didn't
realize how pricey it is but I guess
like how the person will explain
that's all they always tell that to you
you're like yeah next to your car
the next biggest investment because I
was sleeping off the next 20 years it's
true though in his life you're going to
weigh a lot of beds and the last one
that I got I spent like you know two
three g's on it I don't think I'll ever
get rid of it like I missed that bed
when I go to hotels now yeah well cuz
before I'll go to hotels like [ __ ] my
dad you forgot like this whatever Paul
spent two-thirds even maybe 3/4 of his
life in the beds later every day that's
true not yeah but you can I eat in there
- I know just sleep you sleep a lot
exercise working on so much ha ha ha
yeah I'm when I wake up in the morning I
get out of my bed like a second before I
have to leave the house like um I don't
know I can stay up really good but I
don't wake up really that's me too
it's how I woke up this morning is
waking up my daughter two and a half
year old daughters there to see her
butts right in my face but laughs and
then I go the other way my five and a
half year old son is there wearing a
Darth Vader costume again I walk in the
face with a lightsaber hockey ah so you
get up really quickly when you have you
know they're good alarm yeah the winkler
yes I had Darth Vader and my back I
guess but on my bed you were saying
there was one time where your kids like
didn't wake you up because you don't
you're not used to setting an alarm now
the other kids they just wake you up but
like there was one day you remember you
were late you were running so late
because they didn't come like jump on
you in the morning cuz they slept you
should have punished them like you had a
lazy [ __ ] yeah like to work with you
there is a system here yeah well back in
the days they used to put bourbon on the
socket thing and the kids would sleep so
good so long now you'd get child
services knocking on your door don't
tell him that I did that backfired yeah
so there's this woman named Anna she's
playing six years old and she landed the
dream job of testing sofa every day for
ten hours a day
oh you see educator she is a marketing
expert so that's how I guess he narrowed
it down and she bought our jets or just
I don't know that's a good question
imagine her butt is insured now - like
if she loses her but she loses
everything just I feel there's on a
marketing expert is that an actual title
is that what she calls herself because
I'm also eating expert and that's not a
legit marketing experts not a title okay
so that bear tests couches I know what I
know I don't know whatever that that's a
really lifelike human stuff Donna Thank
You Suzanne enjoying her new digs maybe
we're working for a company or a master
yeah so this Russian furniture giant
called mv5 groups the in oceans it's all
cool things behind it all it's a scam so
they announced that they were looking
for a full-time sofa tester and they
received like hundreds of applicants all
from America actually 100,000 ago I five
thousand to read back and so they're
saying like they were able to narrow it
down to seven candidates and that's how
they ended up picking Emma out of the
seven she right now on a three-month
probation to see like how good of a
service for testers you but she was
receiving about $1,000 a month and
salary for this job mm-hmm not that much
though a thousand books some fun yeah
yeah ten hours a day yeah is it ten
hours like five days a week I'm not sure
if it is like ten hours it's only like
one day out of the week
so they said full-time to shift the
rider well more oh wait this is Russia
Russia oh it's not a thousand dollars a
month here it's in Russia oh so it's not
like a lot over there maybe it's normal
out there but isn't it that it is also
this country they don't get the same no
matter if you're a doctor if you're sit
on a sofa really yeah that's the whole
communism right that's why it's very
unmotivated to deliver a lot of heart
well what a [ __ ] not my head can I get
that job [ __ ] I don't want I don't want
to rush of my couches have like an anti
rating now like Anna give it like a four
oh yeah is it like her face on the couch
now
do you look it up what she thought Matt
that's a good question Excel dresses
yeah it's not a personal experience like
I love my coaches when there's a lot of
room and there's a there's a big pillow
that syncs me in that I can like feel
comfortable after a long day of work in
our filming and I come there and I put a
Family Guy
or something and I'm just there where
she might like a completely different
like you know a church chair how do I
know how can I rely on her right I guess
she's the expert yeah I guess that's how
we had to just determine during a
downturn and that's why she was like in
that three-month probation but yeah they
were saying that they do have people
testing their sofas in their own like
specialized laboratory in they call it
but they wanted some like real life use
feedback so that's why they opened the
platform for anyone to kind of jump in
and apply for that position I feel like
you need a whole panel of people like
one per like if there was like ten couch
people I feel like then you get it
better sort of overall wait are you
saying here you're going into a
furniture store buy a sofa and all of a
sudden about ten people debate should or
shouldn't get it now that is an average
rating of that of the couch people I
think they should have like a show like
you know like America's Got Talent it
should be like this couch got comfort
so each couch gets pulled out and you
have three judges that you have Ludacris
you have Pinkerton you have like Mariah
Carey and y'all sit on and they lay on
it no musician they all get the judge
how much comfort the couch has and make
a show out of that watch it but we need
to add in Howie Mandel who was a German
public and he's not sitting on any of
those cultures does my house germs on it
but he can he can talk about the
aesthetics of the couch itself but I
guess that's not what this is about
well yeah I mean it's like the overall
like just the entire couch like this
thing the function of it how comfortable
it is all that stuff she said she's
definitely making some improvements or a
suggesting improvement oh she isn't this
is already like evil is she
I was she looking to cut on what's her
dream here what's the next step in her
career
what's the hangman it's a bunch of but
sitting on sofa
I'm annex bucks and they know their
social did she but manager did she
replace someone like the Santa Claus or
like if someone died and it's like we
need a new couch god no no they just
came up with this and I we need an
average person to test couches for us
that's why they're calling it like a
dream job she's just chillin for ten
hours are they testing the sexuality of
the couch - you know consciousness for
comfort but there's also sex parts of it
so for her to get like a fair rating you
have to see how well it is used for
doggy style but also for holding a kid
and also for like your dogs to jump on
and rest on it - right
the durability the durability if people
sit on the back or the arm like how's
that going it one couch for 10 hours or
like she just works for 10 hours a day
you have to be like all right like this
is my couch for the day looks seem happy
and whether she sleeps on a job was not
doing her job if she sleeps on the job
their ability of it I bet she's pleased
for like seven of the ten hours probably
yeah I don't know surprise me come from
you yeah I wish absolutely all this
great couch
bring the next one Wow yeah and I'm not
sure like what else she has to they
don't have chairs there it's just
couches that's out of her jurisdiction
that's another person I don't know if
it's on [ __ ] because he's not good
have you seen the media there's bunch of
dudes doing this air hump or like this
sofa well you choose YouTube search it
like air hump because there's like bonza
bunch of kids really going down on a
sofa Wow I like a 16 to 18 year olds
like she's wearing boxers and they're
pulling all these sexual moves on it
they're like really deserving what kind
of exciting is it like that grin on
Regina they had an on vine like years
ago
you do get yeah yeah I'd be like
dropping to the floor link rhyming but
it's on a couch you're saying it's on a
couch and there's like I just [ __ ]
the [ __ ] out of it think that you can
put your feet on ottoman
yeah the ottoman
I just bought one that's why mm-hmm I
felt violated for the whatever that
brings out well that's why we need like
one expert you like if you let everyone
do it were just me humping cogsa Natalie
I don't need no expert I'm [ __ ]
expert me too
I trust my own ass well I guess there's
more to the company not really the
consumer oh good I would not like to do
that I'd be so dead tired bored
hi I'm on my buck yeah you can do want
you to jazz like what's the challenge oh
there's another cause I'm gonna put my
ass on it yeah I would you do now for a
living what's your dream job either
wanted to be a ninja or the sheriff of
the town or a duty huh then just don't
get paid do they yeah they're assassins
are they yet mercenaries a side gig for
ninjas I feel like they're mostly just
like sneaking around like that's what
they do it'll die no wrong fascinating
they they advantage they poop and they
sneak in the shadows they're spies
they're assassins or stupid arsonists
there's sabotager silicon industry evil
why does everyone want to be a ninja
because they're [ __ ] cool yeah that's
nothing cooler than being a ninja your
Navy SEALs
you never wanted to be a silent assassin
that lurks in the shadows and fine I'll
be the ninja that the anti ninja like
the Robin Hood of ninja yeah I'll be
like well would not want to be in Hawaii
I'll be in black also but yeah I'll be
something a bad name you know GI Joe
yeah would you be a snake guys or would
you be Storm Shadow who is you oh my god
Cobra Commander John with this
conversation
nope a lady twin well Jay can use
phantoms I hope you guys liked that
video once again remember if you want to
be involved just submit some article in
while suck your dick no but seriously
though there's more videos up there
[Music]